-Ugh.
Oh, cheer up, dummy.
Your book is a huge success.
Everybody loves you.
You just won a Golden Globe.
If you can't be happy tonight,
maybe you'll never be
happy again.
I'm sorry, is that supposed
to be encouraging?
Because it's super-bleak.
Vincent Adultman.
-How are things
at the old nine-to-five?
-Good.
I went
to the stock market today.
I did a business.
I keep telling him
he works too hard.
Come on, Vincent, let's get away
from the rat race.
Take a cruise someplace wet
and Latin.
I mean, can you imagine
this body in a swimsuit?
I literally cannot.
Vincent, let's do a lap.
Have you met Brendan Fraser?
Whoa. Easy, easy.
I got to hand it to Diane.
This book has been everything
she said it would be.
Yeah, she knows
what she's doing.
How is Diane?
I haven't seen her in a while.
Oh, well, the book's been huge
for her, too.
She's practically as famous
as I am now.
-And how are you?
-Well, it's been really hard--
Erica, is that you?
Who let you out
of the burn ward?
Ugh.
Hey, did Vincent seem
extra weird to you last night?
Well, he's still three kids
in a trench coat, so, no.
We're going through
a rough patch.
It's hard, you know?
He's works a fulltime job
at the business factory,
so when he gets home,
he just wants to unwind
by watching R-rated movies.
-(SIGHS) I thought I was ready
for a real adult relationship.
-But--
-(SNORES)
Enough about me.
BoJack, you are on fire.
Oh, are we talking
about me again?
We have an offer on the table
for you to play the bad guy
in the new James Bond.
-Ehh.
-I agree. Total garbage.
But this, it's a new drama
from the Coen Brothers.
A western
about a one-horse town.
And you're the horse.
What do you think?
I think now's the time
to finally make "Secretariat."
Aren't you a little, um,
very too old?
You asked me
what I wanted to do.
That's all I've ever wanted.
And if I can't get it now,
then all of this
has been for nothing.
Oh, fish. Of course!
Why would you ever
make things easy for me
when instead,
you could make things
incredibly difficult?
Laura, clear out
the rest of my day.
I have to push
a boulder up a hill,
and then have it roll over me
time and time again
with no regard for my wellbeing.
Attagirl.